as app developers it's our job to
maintain the illusion that once started
every app is waiting patiently in the
background looking for its chance to be
the star when called on so whenever the
user switches back to your app whether
or not the system has killed it in the
interim they should be presented with
the same UI they had when they left to
help Android has a pair of handlers
specifically for persisting state in
these circumstances unsaved instance
date is called immediately before on
pause so as soon as your app is no
longer active and on restore instant
state is called immediately after on
create but only if the app is being
restarted after having been terminated
by the system that means you can read
the bundle of state information saved
the last time your app was moved from
the foreground here the next time your
user switches to your app even if it was
killed by the system in the meantime
using that bundle you can return your UI
to the same state it was the last time
the user saw it creating a seamless
transition that hides the resource
management happening under the covers
that's enough of the why let's go back
to Dan and see how to put this theory
into practice